[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings as we
celebrate the holidays we're also
remembering those who served our nation
including service members who fought in
afghanistan iraq and syria there's now a
bipartisan push on capitol hill to build
a memorial on the national mall to honor
their sacrifice but the effort has run
into some political obstacles in
congress chris van cleave reports on the
fight to overcome those hurdles
chief warrant officer jonathan farmer
loved every minute with his family that
is silly the 37 year old special forces
soldier was killed by an isis suicide
bomber while deployed to syria in 2019 a
father of four he is one of about 7 000
u.s service members killed in the
20-year global war on terror what do you
miss the most about your husband his
hugs after a long day
his hugs
that was the most healing thing and
dancing
he loved dancing we met his wife tabitha
and his two oldest children betsy and
devin on the national mall where they
hope one day a memorial to his sacrifice
will stand it's been 20 years and
everyone keeps talking about we will
always remember we will always do this
and this is the time this is how we
remember them
the effort to build a national global
war on terrorism memorial was authorized
by congress in 2017 but it didn't
specify when or where construction would
begin it will be built with private
donations and three sites on the
national mall have been proposed
allowing the remembrance of our longest
war to share hollowed ground with
memorials to our founding fathers world
war ii korea and vietnam senator from
west virginia but that effort hit a snag
in september the president reserving the
right to object when senator joe manchin
blocked an effort to fast track a law
calling for its construction on the
national mall which is typically not
allowed i believe this president would
reopen the fight to locate other
memorials on the national mall and
create more controversy that will
ultimately delay the construction of
this world it would be a slap in the
face to all of the gold star families
and to all of those who have served
it's it's not right this has been our
nation's longest war iowa senator joni
ernst a republican and new hampshire
democrat maggie hassan are leading a
bipartisan effort to mandate the global
war on terror memorial be built on the
mall at least 54 other senators are also
on board getting agreement across the
aisle shouldn't be hard exactly when you
think about our veterans men and women
who serve
don't ask each other what political
party they're in as they go into danger
on behalf of their fellow americans they
work together for the cause of freedom
we know that it is the right thing to do
to place a global war on terror memorial
on the national mall we all know that
but again bureaucracy is getting in the
way for now the memorial is on hold the
foundation that will build it can't
start the design process without a
location and senator ernst an iraq war
combat veteran doesn't want to keep
families like the farmers waiting we
want to make sure that we're able to
honor those that have participated in
our nation's most recent war while they
are still with us
many of them are questioning does my
country understand
the sacrifice that i gave and we want to
tell them that yes we honor you what
would it mean for your family to have a
memorial on the mall it would mean
everything this is where everyone comes
to see our national memorials
now the bill actually unanimously passed
a senate committee chaired by joe
manchin the senators are now hoping to
attach it to the national defense
spending bill that the senate will take
up next week the foundation intends to
not only break ground but complete
construction and open the memorial to
the public perhaps right back there
by the end of the decade dana
chris a generation of men and women in
their service and as so many said in
that piece you don't want that slap in
the face at this point thank you